on a constaté que vous aviez une
certaine appétence pour les passeports
mais bon après tout chacun a ses
marottes
mais ce qui est quand même un peu
étrange c'est que s'agissant du
passeport diplomatique dont vous avez
demandé le renouvellement
premièrement vous avez demandé
serez-vous de renouvellement au moment
où après une sanction qui vous était
arrivé qui a été donc terminée vous avez
été déchargé de la mission de
l'organisation des voyages du président
de la république
donc il peut sembler étrange quand vous
que vous demandiez un passeport
diplomatique au moment où n'avez vous
n'avez plus la mission qui justifierait
l'attribution le renouvellement du
passeport diplomatique
première question pourquoi avez vous
demandé ce passeport diplomatique alors
que vous n'aviez plus la fonction qui
aurait justifié que vous le demandiez
deuxièmement vous n'êtes pas passés par
le service du protocole de l'elysée
pourquoi puisque c'est la voie normale
vous avez obtenu ce passeport ce
renouvellement très rapidement auprès du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui en
a d'ailleurs informé monsieur le drian
nous l'a dit le service du protocole de
l'elysée qui après d'après nos
informations n'a pas réagi d'aucune
sorte
d'après nos informations donc je vous
pose ces questions pourquoi avez vous
demandé le renouvellement à cette époque
là pourquoi et pourquoi n'êtes vous pas
passer par le service du protocole alors
je suis désolé monsieur le sénateur mais
les conditions d'attribution de
détention et d'obtention
c'est que de restitution de ces
passeports concerne l'information
judiciaire en cours et j'aurai des
questions donc de deux juges
d'instruction qui sont saisis là dessus
donc je ne répondrai pas à ces questions
devant votre commission je suis désolé
monsieur
là vous êtes obligé de répondre à ces
questions devant notre commission elle
concerne le fonctionnement de l'état et
non pas des fautes que vous auriez pu
commettre
et elles ne sont donc pas reliés à cette
information judiciaire sauf en avoir une
compréhension particulièrement extensif
je vous précise d'ailleurs mais je l' ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois que nos missions
sont complémentaires
nous pouvons nous intéresser aux mêmes
faits mais pas pour le même objet la
justice que s'intéresser à l'utilisation
que vous faites un passeport
diplomatique s'il ya une infraction dans
cette utilisation par vous mêmes nous ne
nous intéresserons pas du tout ça en
revanche il est très important pour nous
d'assumer notre mission
constitutionnelle 100 ans en arrière
limiter les capacités d'action de la
justice nos missions sont
complémentaires et pas concurrentes sur
ce qui concerne les procédures
administratives qui ont eu lieu nous
voulons savoir comment cette attribution
a eu lieu elle n'est pas poursuivie en
tant que tel comme une infraction non
pas l'attribution de ce passeport
diplomatique alors que la justice vous
pose des questions là-dessus
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
qu'elle le fasse mais nous vous posons
aussi des questions là dessus et vous
êtes obligés d'y répondre
j'ai bien entendu votre propos monsieur
présent sûr mais je suis désolé je vous
monsieur président bart excusez-moi j'ai
vu
je ne pourrais pas répondre à cette
question parce que contrairement à ce
que vous affirmez la justice s'intéresse
aux conditions de délivrance et
d'obtention de l'ensemble des passeports
et pas seulement les passeports
diplomatiques dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
sur cinq
motif d'infraction et pas seulement
lusage j'ai été mis en examen en effet
simplement sur l' usage abusif d'un
document de notre fonction mais je suis
placé comme témoin assisté sur quatre
chefs d'inculpation
ce n'est pas tant mon statut que
l'ouverture d'une information sur ces
cinq chefs d'inculpation qui m'empêche
de répondre à cette question
g rappelez nous c'est cinq chefs
d'informations s'il vous plaît le
pensent ils ont été rendus publics par
le parquet monsieur le président bah oui
mais monsieur monsieur vénale à notre
question ne porte pas sur l' usage d'un
passeport il ne porte pas sur le notre
question ne porte pas sur les passeports
de service par rapport à laquelle vous
êtes témoin assisté il porte sur les
conditions d'obtention du renouvellement
d'un passeport alors que vous êtes dans
une institution l'elysée et nous voulons
mener c'est pas parce que la justice
fait son travail que nous ne devons pas
faire le nôtre c'est très clair et c'est
une question absolument essentiel pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain
ou bien on pense que les commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires ne doivent pas
exercer leurs missions
constitutionnelles qui est de contrôler
le gouvernement est d'évaluer les
politiques publiques ce qui se passe à
l'elysée notamment en matière de
sécurité relève de la politique publique
à partir du moment où vous les lisez non
pas l'elysée vous au sein de l'elysée
demandé et obtenu un tel passeport
diplomatique
nous sommes en droit de vous interroger
pour la sur la question de savoir
pourquoi cela a été demandé
alors que vous n'aviez plus
deux titres à disposer d'un passeport
diplomatique et pourquoi vous avez
contre ou a été contournée je ne dis
même pas vous a été contourné le service
du protocole de l'elysée et voilà la
question est très simple subhanallah
alors je vais réitérer mon propos une
troisième fois
la justice étant saisi des faits
concernant les passeports au sens large
et les passeports de service et les
passeports diplomatiques
s'intéressant également aux conditions
d'obtention de ces passeports et non pas
simplement conditions d'utilisation une
information judiciaire étant ouverte et
étant très respectueux des institutions
je répondrai aux questions des
magistrats instructeurs monsieur b nana
permettez moi de vous dire que ce n'est
pas être très respectueux des
institutions que de refuser de répondre
aux questions qui vous sont posées par
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
vous avez une conception singulière de
ce que c'est que le respect des
institutions je dois vous dire que le
respect des institutions
c'est aussi savoir que l'autorité
judiciaire n'a pas le droit de porter
d'appréciation sur une décision
administrative et par conséquent c'est
bien à nous de le faire chacun a son
rôle complémentaire la justice vérifiera
si vous avez ou non commis des
infractions
à ce titre elle peut tout à fait
chercher des informations dans tel ou
tel domaine de l'action administrative
mais ne peut porter d'appréciation sur
la régularité d'une décision
administrative ce qui est une évidence
pour tout le monde et vous qui avez fait
des études de droit vous devriez le
savoir aussi je vois votre obstination à
ne pas répondre aux questions de la
commission denquête et je n'en comprends
pas la raison je tenais à vous lui direz
je rends la parole à monsieur sueur
juste monsieur bah pour essieu benalla
si vous voulez je n'ai absolument rien à
cacher quant à l'obtention et
l'utilisation de ces passeports et j'en
serais aujourd'hui
le premier ravi de pouvoir vous
expliquer comment j'ai pu les obtenir et
comment ils m'ont été délivré et comment
je les ai utilisés
sauf que dès lors qu'il ya une suspicion
que les conditions de délivrance ont
donné lieu à une infraction pénale
on n'est plus dans un cadre
administratif mais dans un cadre
judiciaire et aujourd'hui la justice
s'intéresse à savoir comment j'ai obtenu
ces passeports
donc je vous réitère pour la quatrième
fois que je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question qui n'est pas une
question d'ordre administratives mais
d'ordre judiciaire sur canal à la
justice intéresse-t-elle vraiment aux
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
obtenu le renouvellement de votre
passeport diplomatique au mois de juin
dernier
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai entendu le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république à utiliser l'article 40 du
pote 2 du code de procédure pénale non
pas pour l'attribution de ces passeports
diplomatiques mais pour la note à
en-tête du chef de cabinet du président
de la république par laquelle a été
demandé le renouvellement de votre
passeport de service qui n'a rien à voir
avec le renouvellement de votre
passeport diplomatique au mois de juin
dernier mais nous en resterons là je
vous donne acte de votre refus de
répondre mais je tiens à vous dire que
votre interprétation est erroné et que
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas à opposer à
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
votre propre interprétation par rapport
à celle que nous faisons car c'est notre
rôle d'interpréter notre mandat est de
définir le champ des questions que nous
avons à vous poser et auxquelles vous
pourriez répondre j'ai précisé en
commençant cette audition à quel point
nous sommes de ce point de vue très
attentif à faire en sorte que la
séparation des pouvoirs soient respectés
et la conception que vous en affirmé est
de mon point de vue comme de celui des
rapporteurs abusive alors j'ai bien
entendu encore une fois votre remarque
monsieur le président bah je suis assez
inquiet de voir qu'une première fois
devant votre commission le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république a
évoqué que j'allais être convoqué dans
les toutes prochaines heures
ce qui pose quand même des questions sur
l'indépendance
des institutions et aujourd'hui vous
êtes en train de m'expliquer que vous
n'avez pas connaissance que dans le
dossier la justice s'intéresse à la
condition d'obtention et de délivrance
de ces passeports
je ne sais pas si vous avez eu accès au
dossier judiciaire vous même mais ça me
pose question quand même monsieur
monsieur veine là aussi vénal là je me
fonde sur les chiffres sur les chefs
d'un cri vie nation et sur les
déclarations du parquet lui-même